let's get to some audience questions
starting with Willa Willa wrote in hey
David what's hard to go back to the
cheap version of after you've had the
nice version um I have a couple thoughts
on this you could apply this to almost
anything any area of life coffeemakers
as people know yeah I have never owned a
Keurig and I have disdained for Keurigs
but about two years ago for my birthday
I was always getting just weird gifts
from people that I would never use so
what I told everybody was get me an
Amazon gift card for any amount you want
because I'm going to get myself a nice
espresso machine and people got me gift
cards on Amazon and I pulled it all
together and then added like $90 and got
a nice espresso machine and I can't go
back now to crappy coffee machine that
must have been expensive it was an
expensive machine but it cost me 90
bucks because I just told everybody hey
here this is if you what you want to
really get me something I want
get me an Amazon gift card yeah I'm
thinking about like a quality car like
if you get used to a car with like front
seat arm rests and heated seats and
maybe something like the safety features
like blind spot protection warnings or
and a backup camera I mean how are you
going away from that to like a 1997
chevrolet monte carlo well you know that
now I'm pretty sure that backup camera
is standard on all cars ooh I think is
that true I don't even know I think that
that is true that every carbon has a
backup camera uh yeah I could see that I
could see that and you know I think part
of this is that hedonic adaptation that
people talk about which is once you
upgrade some element of your lifestyle
within some short period of time you
become accustomed to it and it becomes
your new normal it becomes your new
baseline and then you're just kind of
looking for the next thing and going
backwards is very very tough yeah we
typically think about as like a bad
thing because your standards are going
up and up and up and maybe you don't
deserve to get better and better things
now serve very paternalistic view I mean
what if like you're a musician right and
you just start out and the first guitar
that you buy is say worth $100 yeah and
then your talents improve I mean you you
deserve to get maybe like a $500 or
$1,000 guitar what does deserve mean
though in that context you've earned it
into in skill for the time that you put
into it
okay the fact that your skills are
improving all that stuff yeah but then a
lot of people put in the same amount of
time and they still can't afford the
better guitar so haven't they also
earned it yeah but I mean you gotta be
able to afford it I guess and that's
it's your problem yeah that well that is
exactly the problem I think that we're
talking about shaving razors I used to
have really crappy razors and then
through the show actually we got
sponsorship from a number of different
like better nicer razor manufacturers
and now I've been completely spoiled by
like the nice heavy safety razor and I
can't go back to those temporary things
that bitter disposables that weigh like
a fraction of an ounce it just feels not
good you know yeah I don't change my
blades too often oh really not like I
can't even grow a full beard right you
know yeah I'd like to be able to I've
actually stopped shaving I haven't
shaved in nine months and this is this
is what it looks like which is shocking
a lot of people in the audience yeah I
once was upgraded to first class on an
international flight and let me tell you
it is tough to go back after that I
actually go into Argentina in August I
had all these frequent flyer miles oh
yeah of course it's like impossible to
use them unless you want to fly
specifically on like three days within a
month you might be looking to travel or
whatever so I had the opportunity to I
had bought the ticket an economy ticket
but I had the opportunity to use the
miles to upgrade it to first-class or
with it I guess they call now
international business class and it's
it's better it's better and going back
is tough but if there's like a two-hour
flight I don't think there would be such
a big transition to go back to sure but
if it's like you're fine half our world
and you're gonna be sleeping yeah it's
much better to be able to like lie down
and get those blankets and those warm
cookies that you get oh the blankets in
the warm cookies are stunning yeah ya
know it was a game changer for a ten and
a half hour hour flight and once you
move forward it's tough to move back and
reality hits you pretty quick when you
do that